[Music]
in evil co-worker news oh damn oh damn
submitted by [ __ ] jones a man was
arrested under suspicion of killing 21
co-workers by poisoning their food what
how could we do here but real that's you
how big is this factory they can get
away with 21 murders this must not be in
the US because I always exactly China
well we'll see you Foxconn planners I
would immediately been the first death
cuz everytime co-workers got something
to eat and they want to share with me oh
yeah
I'll [ __ ] eat that [ __ ] ah do you guys
wanna guess where this place China India
any other guys nah cuz I don't picture
them sharing that much food I say China
I say south somewhere south america i
say nebraska and they all wear matching
bands that's a cold yep
so that took place in Germany oh I was
close Nebraska yeah I was closer yeah
this takes place in Germany and they're
investigating this 56 year old suspect
by the name of Heimlich cooter Berger no
he actually it's a pretty German name
what is it I can't find it now but it's
a pretty German name it's like Joseph
Venus's
I'll tell you when I find it what job
was it you can't just control that
[ __ ] I know
well I remember his name's how can I
control find it oh yeah sure name you
can control fine name
no wait unknown known David uh yeah I
don't know I failed you guys what names
Heimlich [ __ ] boom it's official it's
a fair
so that's the name for sure the new
Voter was created to buy me Heimlich ah
sounds pretty evil yeah so this dude has
been working at this company for 38
years and uh damn it's a metal fittings
company oh so what's that
factory yeah like a factory kind of
thing and he just was a disgruntled why
I guess China mmm yeah so apparently
what he did so there have been 21
employees I have died since 2000
oh thanks for your job well so he's been
poisoning throughout the years oh okay
yeah they finally caught him when there
was this employee that saw some
suspicious white powder on his sandwich
and they he went to the management and
they reviewed security footage and they
saw this man Wow in that man sandwich
that's crazy and so at first they
thought it was like a weird prank but
then they tested that powder and they
found it to be rat poisoning uh lead
poisoning kind of complain so has he
been like over the like years just like
slowly killing them pretty much oh man
yeah because some employees like they've
gotten cancer they've had heart failure
also they're not dying from like
poisoning all the time from random Asha
Oh could like their health is failing
it's like destroying they're all like
yeah Heimlich is the only healthy one
out of the co-workers like let's
investigate what I was thinking is the
Gestapo is [ __ ] doing some shitty
police work
because if 21 people over the course of
like 18 years from the same company has
been dying of poisoning well kind of got
a point at the company but but yeah they
PI thought it was the unhealthy
conditions of the metal and yet cuz
they're not dying from poisoning they're
dying from cancer whatever because that
pip that poison is making them their
health fail that's like oh he died from
pneumonia or whatever it was suspicion
because people put PI thought just from
working in that Factory
you know exactly so then now they're
investigating this and it's just crazy
because yeah this time
they went to his home and they found
substances used to make poison which
included mercury lead and cabin mmmm
so you just hated these dudes with like
all these employees there's no known
motive right now I bet you it's like
these guys were gonna take his position
or they he saw them as a threat because
they worked too good I bet you it's of
all about power mm-hmm
it's just that he you have control over
people's lives and [ __ ] oh man that's I
don't think I hate anyone enough to like
ever want to slowly kill him oh I like
good that could pick some people out
everybody check your teas right now
check your arsenal y'all take your SIP
teeth we're immune to poison job yeah so
apparently he has the suspect has chosen
to remain silent after his arrest so
we've got the fifth out there too damn
yeah so we don't have a known motive as
it right now damn it's crazy and they're
gonna they're even considering exhuming
the people that have died like getting
their bodies in testing I should have
done that like right after [ __ ] they
died and found out a cause but if they
have cancer that we never lost all right
right yes so they're saying that they're
trying to see if these people who are
with an ill they if it's because of
heavy metal poisoning which is what he
was doing all these people just crazy
that's evil [ __ ] right there that's
pretty [ __ ] crazy you would think
that if you hated your co-workers you're
just trying to find another job but me
loved this job so much is like I'm not
leaving Worley look everybody has Co
work like co-workers you hate you know
thought the years are working those jobs
and hating sir but why couldn't he be
like normal people and just sabotage
them and get them fired just PETA they
sexually harassed you he's gonna get
fired after so many people like I would
just steal their life steal you start
killing people - no pee in their coffee
or something I don't know
yeah I mean do what no okay so this is
what normal people do in companies they
believe their co-workers they annoy them
they sabotage their work they [ __ ]
get them drunk after work and by the
briefing yeah they do let what you do
hold things to is credit card in for you
buy something yeah you log into their
computer [ __ ] up their job post the [ __ ]
on you can get their phone and like
start texting pee yeah you go to a
[ __ ] gas station stop in the middle
of the desert and then you say wanna
[ __ ] and then you put their phone number
in yeah you log into their computer you
send your boss pull on yep you say
important documents from our meeting
yeah it's a body builder jacking off
it's just some guy free bull jacking
yeah under camera said in those videos
where they got a stare and then a ghost
pops up and it scares ya or sex night
well then it's like making the moaning
noise out loud put the volume down and
[ __ ] do that those are harmless that's
pretty cool that's funny you send those
to your friends that'll get you fired
you know what I keep looking for his
name cuz I remember hearing him sound
his name I think I got it mixed up with
a different article so sorry guys
I can't find it booting burger yeah it's
Heimlich cooter Berger yeah then that
burger sounds fire chili and that
[ __ ] hoodoo you're the first like
millennial I've met who'd says fire like
normally and just know honestly it's an
annoying habit like what are the hobbies
just said all the time now is just
implemented into my vocab I didn't sound
like I didn't even recognize you said
fire it's absolutely fire its fire I
think [ __ ] they're like like I'm like oh
dude my accountant is fire he kills my
taxes Oh Klaus
oh so did you did you guys say clothes
no clown sounds good I like clouds at
the closet coming um yeah like Santa
Klaus I'm down word Klaus Santa Klaus
the German Santa
those come in have you guys ever seen
the German forklift safety video so
boring a guy named Klaus oh it's [ __ ]
hilarious house it's a it's a it's a
video I think it was a bit obviously but
it's about how to operate and use a
forklift in a factory and this guy like
by the end of it he gets every single
one of his limbs cut off and like it's
[ __ ] hilarious it's great it's a
comedy it's a comedy but it's from years
ago I was like and the early days in the
internet this is like one of the first
videos that I downloaded and took like
three days and [ __ ] on LimeWire oh [ __ ]
those days yeah Kazan oh yeah that was
James I remember finding early comedy
like on on plays bearshare LimeWire
Napster what am i one of my favorite
German singers is actually this Japanese
guy that took up yodeling and became a
famous yodeler and he wears traditional
German clothes any yodels with chickens
and [ __ ] you guys should watch with
chickens what are the chicken students
type in Japanese yodels
no but the world needs to see this [ __ ]
yeah this shit's the [ __ ]
there's old school footage there's new
school footage about Japanese you're
Japanese
yodeler yeah new baby handle yeah let me
show you this much as it says Joe trying
to get views on his [ __ ] oh my god this
guy's already hilarious with the sound
off
why South Vietnamese like I yes like the
cheese we karaoke music in the
background unless you look like Michael
I swear I swear heard this not see
today's hilarious exiling how come it's
eyebrows are the only black I've seen is
that Korean karaoke actually one of the
many hazards are random visuals like I
use like white people on a jet ski while
you're singing Whitney Houston's I've
always loved you it's like because how
do you see I've done the Kidsongs there
they did there's some [ __ ] creepy ass
hilarious kids like Kidz Bop yeah next
time you're at Korean karaoke hot tip
choose any of the kids songs and go do
the karaoke to that it's [ __ ] a riot
I was just had a buddy of mine had a
birthday and we were at Korean karaoke
and he picked the kids songs and it was
like it was the the footage matched it
was like some Korean kids show with like
people in animal costumes while they
sing this inane [ __ ] song about
traveling the world or whatever it was
great
[Music]
[Music]